[Musik]
trümmer zerstörung chaos teile perus in
schutt und asche
noch immer sind nicht alle opfer
geborgen ein land unter schock einen tag
nach der schweren explosion gestern
abend im hafen von beirut
herzlich willkommen zu einem zdf spezial
die serie hält verschiebt sich um circa
zehn minuten von einer katastrophe im
wahrsten sinne des wortes spricht der
libanesische gesundheitsminister
apokalypse wie beim abwurf einer
atombombe
so beschreiben es augenzeugen über 100
tote tausende verletzt wohl
hunderttausende obdachlos über die
dramatische situation vor ort kein felix
johannes große teile der libanesischen
hauptstadt liegen in trümmern
der hafen von beirut verwüstet die
menschen im schockzustand
meine auto stand da hinten es liegt auf
dem kopf das herumfliegende glas hat
mich verletzt
das ist von meinem auto übrig
ich sah meine frau blutüberströmt am
kopf getroffen keiner half alle
kümmerten sich nur um sich selbst keiner
um irgendjemand andere
hunderttausende sind auf hilfe
angewiesen sie zu leisten oft unmöglich
rund ein kilometer entfernt vom
explosionsort ein krankenhaus schwer
getroffen hier weitere patienten
aufzunehmen ausgeschlossen
alle fünf stockwerke sind beschädigt sei
der nacht evakuieren wir die patienten
wir versorgen sie notdürftig außerhalb
des gebäudes die kliniken die jetzt noch
helfen können hat schon die korona
pandemie an ihre leistungsgrenzen
gebracht nun kommen tausende verletzte
hinzu
und das sind längst nicht die einzigen
probleme mit dem sich die betroffenen in
beirut konfrontiert sehen der libanon
macht schon so vieles durch viele haben
kaum genug geld um sich essen zu kaufen
die preise für brot haben sich
verdoppelt und jetzt das wie sollen die
menschen im land damit klarkommen
wir erwarten keine hilfe von der
regierung die immer unsere regierung
kümmert sich nicht wir müssen alleine
wieder aufstehen
tag eins nach der explosion der anfang
eines riesigen kraftakt inzwischen haben
mehrere nationen angekündigt hilfsteams
ins land zu schicken sie werden dringend
gebraucht und in beirut ist nun
zugeschaltet ulrich wagner
regionalleiter des deutschen roten
kreuzes guten abend wir haben sie denn
persönlich die explosion erlebt genannt
ich habe die explosion leider sehr
direkt miterlebt aus meiner wohnung
die war etwa einen kilometer vom
explosionsort entfernt und wir haben
eine druckwelle abbekommen wie ich sie
vorher noch nie erlebt habe ich habe
schon den kriegsgebieten gearbeitet aber
noch nie so eine wucht miterlebt zum
beispiel wurde unsere küchenspüle aus
der verankerung gerissen durch die küche
geworfen
überall splitter türen aus den angeln
das war eine schwere verwüstung
glücklicherweise wurde ich nur leicht
verletzt aber als wir dann dass die
wohnung verlassen haben und dann auch
die anderen wohnungen die straßen
gesehen haben dann wurde klar was für
ein ausmaß dieser katastrophe ein fall
eigentlich hat zum beispiel waren die
straßen voll mit glas am rand der
straßen lagen verletzte die im dunkeln
weil das stroh war der strom ausgefallen
war
die im dunkeln notdürftig von ihren
familienmitgliedern versorgt wurden
viele leute versuchten mit den autos
ihre ihre familienmitglieder in die
krankenhäuser zu bringen und wir
arbeiten eng mit dem libanesischen roten
kreuz zusammen die dann auch sehr
schnell raus gefahren sind und versucht
haben die leute zu retten
leider und das ist ja gerade eine der
prioritäten die immer noch ganz akute
ist leider ist halt die medizinische
infrastruktur sehr belastet gerade die
die krankenhäuser haben kein platz mehr
leute wurden abgewiesen weil sie einfach
weil die krankenhäuser keine
bettenkapazität mehr haben und der fokus
war auf den schwerverletzten
das klingt sehr dramatisch was würden
sie denn sagen sind die größten probleme
moment fort also die priorität ist auf
jeden fall die nothilfe der die
medizinische nothilfe zu zu stärken also
die krankenhäuser zu versorgen
materialien ausrüstungsgegenständen und
eben dann auch es sind eher zwischen 200
300 tausend leuten obdachlos geworden
viele können sich keine wohnung leisten
eben essentielle gegenstände zu liefern
so etwas wie seife wasserkanister wie
zum beispiel auch plastikplanen damit
sie ein dach über dem kopf haben und da
arbeiten wir gerade mit dem
libanesischen hohen kreuz an einem
flugzeug was hoffentlich diese woche
solche güter liefert vielen dank für
diese eindrückliche schilderung direkt
aus beirut
da ging die katastrophe trifft in
libanon mitten in einer schweren
wirtschaftskrise
corona verschärft die lage zusätzlich
und die wut der menschen auf ihre als
korrupt geltenden macht elite ist groß
in dieser sowieso schon angespannten
lage jetzt die explosionen im hafen über
das pulverfass bei rot an der rot und
sebastian ihm scheinbar säckeweise ist
das ammonium nitrat gestapelt
ungesichert und hoch explosiv diese
bilder hat die investigativ plattform
berlin kehrt veröffentlicht und anhand
der fotos verifiziert dass sie an einer
lagerhalle am hafen von beirut
aufgenommen wurden
die lagerhalle die gestern brannte und
die später große teile der stadt
verwüstet
es ist noch nicht offiziell bestätigt
dass diese bilder wirklich das zeigen
was viele vermuten nämlich
fahrlässigkeit oder vertuschung der
verantwortlichen eine von vielen
spekulationen
fakt ist die gewaltige explosion von
beirut trifft ein land das ohnehin am
boden liegt die menschen im libanon
leidgeprüft zu besuch bei familie al ali
vor gut einer woche die mutter zeigt
ihren leeren kühlschrank
sie hat acht kinder ich kann es mir
nicht leisten etwas zu kaufen gar nichts
selbst für die kinder kann ich nichts
kaufen
armut und hunger der alltägliche kampf
schätzungsweise ein drittel der
libanesen ist arm
sie müssen mit weniger als 4 us dollar
pro tag leben
die arbeitslosigkeit liegt inzwischen
bei mehr als 30 prozent vor allem junge
libanesen sind ohne perspektive mehr als
60 prozent haben keinen job
die wut auf die regierung ist groß
rückblick herbst 2009 10 zu
hunderttausenden strömen die menschen
auf die straßen beiruts es ist der
beginn der massenproteste in libanon
jeden tag entlädt sich ihre wut über
soziale ungerechtigkeit und wachsende
korruption das land hoch verschuldet
heruntergewirtschaftet durch
missmanagement und korruption der
politischen elite die regierung trat
damals zurück doch verändert hat sich
nichts das system blieb die wut ebenso
beruht gestern mittag nur stunden vor
der explosion
proteste vor dem energieministerium die
menschen haben die stundenlange
stromausfälle satt es kommt zu
auseinandersetzungen
wir wollen alle institutionen
konfrontieren die ihre arbeit nicht tun
nämlich den menschen zu dienen
vor allem das energieministerium die
leute da machen nicht nur einen
schlechten job sie berauben auch die
menschen
die regierung zu schwach unfähig
probleme zu lösen sei es die versorgung
mit elektrizität wasser oder nahrung
die bilder von heute der hafen von
beirut zerstört dabei ist gerade er
überlebenswichtig für dieses land hier
kommen die waren an die die bevölkerung
versorgen
der libanon blickt in eine zukunft die
noch dunkler ist als vor der explosion
und wir schalten nochmal nach kairo zu
joachim paul von der
heinrich-böll-stiftung herr paul wir
haben gesehen wie immens wichtig der
hafen ist für die wirtschaft was
bedeutet denn das für die versorgung im
land das ist eine katastrophe für die
versorgung im land 85 prozent aller
güter die ihr im libanon konsumiert und
verbraucht werden sind importiert die
größte teil davon ist durch diesen hafen
gekommen
der hafen ist weg es gibt noch den hafen
im norden tripoli der hat aber bei
weitem nicht die kapazität und zuvor
hatte schon die krise dazu geführt dass
enorme versorgungsengpässe gab also das
wird ein riesen problem das nicht nur
logistisch für die sondern auch
strukturell für die nächsten monate und
wahrscheinlich jahre hier werden die wut
vieler menschen in beirut auf die
regierung ist ohnehin groß es gab
massive proteste was erwarten sie jetzt
ich werde sagen aber er sie haben es
gesagt die proteste die menschen sind
monatelang massiv millionen auf die
straße gegangen
dann die wirtschaftskrise dann der
corolla lag da und jetzt diese
unglaubliche explosion und zerstörung
ich weiß nicht wie viel die leute noch
auf sich nehmen können
ich erwarte aber dass das die wut auf
die politische klasse die sich gegenüber
jegliche reform abschottet verstärkt und
es ist zu protesten kommen wird
verantwortlichen im hafen wurde heute
erstmal unter hausarrest gestellt wird
dass die gemüter beruhigen wenn sie also
das als alleinige maßnahme
das wird keinesfalls die leute
irgendwie beruhigen oder überzeugen denn
so wie ich das verstehe aus meinen
gesprächen mit den leuten und was ich
hier war nehme diese explosion dieses
riesige unglaubliche so unglaubliche
vorfall
das sechs jahre lang dieses gefährliche
material dort gelagert wurde
das wird jetzt nicht als ein unglück
oder ein unfall gesehen sondern das wird
strukturell in zusammenhang gesehen
gebracht mit der verantwortungslosigkeit
der politischen klasse gegenüber der
eigenen bevölkerung
vielen dank für diese einschätzung ja
auch ein paar beide gespräche nach
beirut haben wir wegen der
stromversorgung in libanon kurz vor der
sendung aufgezeichnet
falls ihr während des gesprächs mit
herrn paul gerade straßengeräusche
gehört haben er hat uns noch erklärt
dass fast kein gebäude im brot mehr
fensterscheiben hat auch nicht dass in
dem er sich befindet
das war unser zdf spezial mehr
informationen zu den folgenden
explosionen jederzeit auf der zdf heute
oder später im heute-journal und
anschließend im ausland schon mal da
sehen wir uns dann wenn sie mögen
hier geht es jetzt weiter mit der serie
hält auf wiedersehen
[Musik]